[Musique]
j'ai rencontré quelqu'un moi je passerai
récupérer mes affaires
quand tout se sera calmé elle mais je
suis calme
du jamais été aussi calme bonjour il est
mignon vous l'avez depuis longtemps trop
longtemps
c'est la grand mère qui m'a légué un
cauchemar soutien à patrick qu'est ce
que tu as mangé encore sinon comment ça
va il dévore tout ce qu'ils trouvent
sauf que je lui sers dans sa gamelle mon
proprio n'intéresse pas les animaux
domestiques
je commence à bosser dans une semaine et
j'ai personnes pour le garder
à part ça je craque la discipline ne
soit pas le point fort de mademoiselle
francis vous ne savez rien noir ni de ma
pédagogie c'est la dernière fois je suis
désolé je the dead est aussi un fou le
temps de se découvrir d'apprendre à se
connaître
oui moi on n'a pas du tout eu les mêmes
expériences au mois lui laisser une
chance
il a l'air d'un gentil petit gars
[Musique]
petit chou je sais trop gentil c'est pas
sûr non avec que je vous propose un
choix là
[Musique]
on
vous étiez en train de sauver une vie ah
non non non je regardais game of thrones
et j'ai pas vu l'air
[Musique]
l'eau
bonjour
vous êtes prêts pour la course
mademoiselle français et chinois
[Musique]
patrick
tu me fiche la trouille c'est quoi c'est
ma façon de conduire
[Musique]